[Musik]
london erwacht aus einem
dornröschenschlaf
nach vier monaten blog da fühlt sich an
wie nach einer langen krankheit einem
koma faszinierend war fing schritt für
schritt öffnen läden lokale theater
stadien bis ende juni könnten alle
einschränkungen fallen
[Musik]
es ist großartig wie die begeisterung in
die stadt zurückkehrt will ich das allem
wieder leben eingehaucht wird eine stadt
die besonders unter corona gelitten hat
nun wird geimpft was das zeug hält
gelockert so lange die infektionszahlen
nicht stark steigen dass große
eröffnungs experimente bei dem hohen
tempo der impfkampagne kriegen wir wohl
gerade die kurve hoffentlich sind wir
nicht zu leichtfertig und verspielen die
fortschritte wieder so weit so gut
für die weltstadt london soll es nun
wieder nur in die eine richtung gehen
auf werte
[Musik]
keine straße der stadt die sie nicht
kennt rachel martin peer seit
jahrzehnten taxifahrerin und tourguide
eine waschechte londoner in die auf
dieser speziellen nach lockdown tour
orte zeigen will die für sie den
neuanfang symbolisieren an denen sich
die metropole zurückkämpft ihrer stadt
er selbst hat corona arg zugesetzt seit
einem jahr halten sie staatliche hilfen
über wasser aber das selbstwertgefühl
könne kein geld der welt ersetzen
es war niederschmetternd in die stadt zu
kommen
ich bin arbeiten gegangen was mich aber
wirklich richtig fertig gemacht hat das
waren niemand auf der straße alles zu
aber jetzt kommen alle zurück und wir
sind angriffslustig diese stadt lasse
sich nicht unterkriegen ergänzt rieschel
es werde wieder gefeiert getanzt gelacht
und eingekauft shopping sei ein motor
der wirtschaft touristenmagnet die im
nobelviertel chelsea dem ersten stock wo
trends gesetzt werden weit über die
stadt hinaus
wie aktuell das feuerwerk der farben zum
anfassen der geruch von neu und
vielleicht gleich dass charlyn broadband
im glück die personal shopperin darf
endlich wieder in den vielen kleinen
motiti stöbern
ich suche nach dem passenden farben und
formen das was meine kundinnen
formvollendet ihnen hilft die innere
stärke zu finden
genau das was viele jetzt bräuchten
da kann es gar nicht bunt genug sein
vier monate eintönigen lockdown im
schlabberlook vergessen machen und
charles tiefrote geschäftszahlen gleich
mit corinna war für personal shopper ein
traumatisches erlebnis davor lief unser
geschäft komplett von angesicht zu
angesicht der persönliche touch ist
wichtig die kundinnen kennen und
verstehen lernen ihre bedürfnisse und
über nacht bricht alles weg nun soll es
wieder die anziehungskraft der
persönlichen begegnung richten dass ihr
klientel viel von im lockdown gesparten
geld ausgibt
[Musik]
was für eine freude endlich wieder
sachen anprobieren ein wenig normales
leben kehrt zurück charles shopping herz
hängt an chelsea überraschend vielfältig
fast zu verführerisch ich versuche
gerade mich beim shoppen zu zügeln
endlich offene geschäfte
da habe ich zu viel geld verprasst
herrlich sich ein wenig verwöhnen zu
können und nach so langer zeit noch
fehlen die touristen soziales auch viele
londoner scheuen den bummel vorsicht
oder die einsicht dass vieles online
geht nirgendwo im land hat die pandemie
so viele jobs gekostet wie in london bis
zu 100.000 allein in einzelhandel und
gastronomie
der weg zur blühenden landschaften ist
weit
auf zu taxifahrerin rage als nächste
station
so hofft dort haben sich bars pubs
restaurants mit online bestellungen
durch die krise gewählt denn das
legendäre vergnügungsviertel lebe doch
so rachel von einer entscheidenden zutat
geselligkeit in euro bekommst du
außergewöhnliches essen auswahl und
vielfalt sind fantastisch mit einer
großen bandbreite an küchenchefs aus
aller welt von denen viele in london
aufgewachsen sind
bei aller vielfalt einigkeit herrscht in
london was im lockdown am meisten
gefehlt hat auswärts essen gehen
ein gepflegtes pint gerne auch wein die
freuden des lebens teilen zu können
[Musik]
das beste was es gibt im pub mit
freunden sein eine zigarette und sich
vergnügen weil ein paar drinks mit viel
zeit zum reden das ausgehviertel wird
zur fußgängerzone jeden meter nutzen
erst mal darf nur im freien kredenzt
werden mediterranes draußen spielt das
leben gefühl in einer stadt eher bekannt
für drin pop steigt die party für viele
fühlte sich seltsam handel der unter
menschen zu sein
du gehst raus und denkst oh was mache
ich denn da hat all diesen leuten hier
schön wieder draussen zu sein
langsam wieder so etwas wie normalität
zu haben das tut gut
seit dieser woche sind nicht nur in
china town sogar die innenbereiche
wieder geöffnet begleitet von einem
mulmigen gefühl nach vielen
lockerungsschritte steigen die
infektionszahlen erstmals wieder die
indische variante macht sich breit doch
für die meisten gilt sorgen wieder
morgen erstmal genießen
[Musik]
wer mehr hochgenuss will so taxifahrerin
rachel lande unweigerlich im westend
neben dem new yorker broadway das
theaterviertel überhaupt corona habe es
hart getroffen aber es sei unverwüstlich
[Musik]
dem austrieb im saint martin vierter ist
die am längsten aufgeführte bühnenschau
der welt eine ikone des westend die
können es kaum erwarten wieder zu öffnen
1952 elisabeth wird zur queen und im
westend feiert agatha christies mouse
trap die mausefalle premiere ohne
unterbrechung geht das ensemble des märz
vergangenen jahres auf die suche nach
dem mörder
[Musik]
28.000 199 mal weltrekord prophetisch
antwortet der erste produzent was das
stück denn aufhalten könne höchstens
eine nationale katastrophe
es braucht gar eine internationale mit
corona sind die bühnen verweist die
mausefalle das gesamte londoner westend
schauplatz einer tragödie
[Musik]
es hat das theater business in die knie
gezwungen vollkommen ich habe mit
anderen schauspielern telefoniert die
ihr selbstbewusstsein verloren haben die
nicht wissen ob sie jemals wieder auf
die bühne dürfen und wenn ja ob sie das
noch wollen es braucht viel harte arbeit
um alles zurück zu bringen
harte arbeit die sich nicht rechnet
wegen der abstandsregeln höchstens halb
volles haus jede vorstellung macht
verluste es geht ums überleben der
mördersuche
doch bevor der tödliche schuss wieder
fällt temperaturkontrolle masken pflicht
die 28.000 zweihundertste vorstellung
dieselbe handlung dazu die erkenntnis
ohne kunst und kultur ist london fiel
seelenloser beton
es bedeutet mir die welt ins theater
gehen zu können großartig zurück im
westend zu sein
alle die hier arbeiten haben praktisch
seit monaten nichts verdient nicht nur
die künstler auch backstage die alle
gilt es zu unterstützen
wer verstehen will wie sehr corona die
stadt erschüttert hat findet antworten
bei taxifahrerin rätsels nächsten halt
gerade lassen wir das parlament hinter
und über die westminster bridge jetzt
sieht man auf der rechten seite da unten
das corona mahnmal menschen die spontan
eine botschaft an die verlorenen
liebsten auf schreiben wollten so ging
es los
nun hoffen alle dass die mauer bleibt
ein stück erinnerungskultur wird
ein herz für jeden corona toten im land
fran hall hat ihren mann verloren einen
tag nach der hochzeit bekommt er
atemprobleme
zwei wochen später beendet corona ihre
ehe
das krankenhaus hat mich informiert als
sie nichts mehr tun konnten
ich durfte die letzten 36 stunden bei
ihm sein was so viele familien nicht
konnten
ich war so froh dass er nicht allein
sein musste
fran sucht nach erklärungen wie
politiker es haben zu lassen können dass
so viele sterben und findet ein wenig
trost in einer mauer 500 meter lang
gegen das vergessen und die ohnmacht
ich fühlte mich hilflos zusehen zu
müssen wie die zahl der toten steigt und
steigt hinter jeder zahl steht ein
mensch mit familie
das repräsentiert jedes einzelne herz
150000 für jeden briten auf dessen
totenschein corona steht jeder fünfte
ein londoner der januar steht für eine
stadt in angst in der kranke nicht mehr
behandelt werden konnten viele herzen
aufhören zu schlagen niemals vergessen
doch der blick geht nach vorn im norden
londons liegt taxifahrerin ray charles
letzte tour halt hier entscheide sich ob
bald wieder große events steigen gut für
die stadt gut fürs geschäft
ob in london oder überall im land für
fußball fans ist es das mekka
massenauflauf in wembley ein traum
englands fußball und konzert heiligtum
wembley bei chelsea gegen leicester
steht nicht nur der sieg im englischen
pokal auf dem spiel sondern auch ob
massenveranstaltungen wieder möglich
sind
20.000 zuschauer so viele wie seit 14
monaten nicht mehr
ein negativer test maximal einen tag
alten pflicht doch davidson sein sohn
und zwei freunde machen wie viele hier
freiwillig zwei mehr ein paar tage davor
und danach als teil einer studie die
zeigen soll ob fußball mit fans sicher
geht
ich bin zweimal geimpft das entspannt
ungemein klar bin ich dazu vorsichtig
aber hier sind alle getestet tickets und
tests bitte fußballspiel experiment und
dankeschön die hälfte der karten wurde
unter mitarbeitern des staatlichen
gesundheitsdienstes verlost unter den
gewinnern die krankenpfleger vishnu und
anis manchester united fans erzählen sie
egal spaß haben nach 14 monaten an
vorderster front im kampf gegen die
pandemie die tickets die wertschätzung
die darin liegt das bedeutet was wir als
pfleger spazieren hier rein um mein gott
jackpot wie soll ich das erklären so
aufregend und die studie mit all den
tests die zeigen wie man solche events
sicher durchführen kann welche
vorsichtsmaßnahmen es braucht das finde
ich enorm wichtig geht alles gut sollen
beim em finale sogar 45.000 zuschauern
selten waren grölende fans vom stadion
lieber gesehen
hauptsache normalität denn noch ist
lange nicht alles wie es war
[Musik]
eines der wahrzeichen allerdings dreht
sich wieder kein stillstand mehr bloß
kein weiterer lockdown stattdessen so
die hoffnung soll london zum symbol
werden über die stadtgrenze hinaus dafür
dass nicht nur dieser ort die pandemie
langsam aber sicher hinter sich lassen
kann
[Musik]